المزيد عن العمليات العسكريه في قطاع غزه
في نافذه التحليل اليوميه مع جلال شهده
اليك جلال غنو الابرز طبعا سقوط عدد كبير
من الجنود والافراد في الجيش الاسرائيلي
بالاضافه الى التقارير التي تتحدث عن
اعاده انتشار او حتى انسحاب لقوات
الاحتلال من المناطق الشماليه لقطاع غزه
اللواء فيز دويري خبير عسكري واستراتيجي
يطلعنا على هذه النقاط وابرز ما قراته
خلال ساعات اليوم ولكن اولا الى عبد
القادر لنطلع على مجرى وسير العمليات
العسكريه وايضا ابرز مواجهات بين الفصائل
الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال نعم جلال ولعلي
انطلق من المنطقه الشماليه تحديدا بالنظر
الى العواجل التي تابعناها فيما يتعلق هذه
المنطقه وبالحديث عن المنطقه الشماليه نحن
نذكر دوما بان هذه المنطقه كانت مسرحا
لاشتباكات بين القوات الاسرائيليه التي
تموقع في مخ مختلف المناطق الشماليه
تحديدا لمدينه غزه مناطق الشماليه لقطاع
غزه وكانت هناك اشتباكات عنيفه على مختلف
محاورها سواء المحاور الشرقيه الشماليه
الشرقيه او الشماليه الغربيه ولكن اللافت
هو ما اعلنته واشنطن بوست نقلا عن مسؤولين
امريكيين نقلا عن مسؤولين اسرائيليين
بانهم فعلا بداوا في الانسحاب من مناطق
عديده في الشمال او يمكن الحديث عن اعاده
تموضع
في هذه المناطق حديث عن الاف من الجنود
وسط تساؤلات طبعا وتحتاج الى تحليل عسكري
حول هذا التموضع الجديد في هذه المنطقه
الشماليه التي كما قلت شهدت اشتباكات
عنيفه قادتها المقاومه على كثير من
المحاور الشجاعيه جباليه مخيم جباليه
وتساؤلات ايضا حول الاهداف التي وضعها
الجيش الاسرائيلي في هذه المنطقه وما اذا
تحققت ام لا كي يتم المرور الى هذه
المرحله جديده هذه التطورات ايضا تاتي
بينما كان الحديث خلال الساعات الماضيه عن
هذا هذين الحادثين حينما اعلن الجيش
الاسرائيلي على انه ربما شهد واحد من اسوا
ايام الحرب منذ بدايتها في السابع من
اكتوبر حينما تحدث عن مقتل تسعه ضباط
وجنود في مناطق الوسط
والجنوب ياتي ذلك بينما كان الحادث الاول
او الهجوم الاول طبعا في ظل ايضا غياب
معلومات دقيقه عما حدث تمثل في انفجار
لشاحنه كان بها ذخائر لتفجير الانفاق وقتل
فيها سته جنود وضباط اسرائيليين في هناك
حديث عن منطقه البريج ولكن ليس مؤكد بشكل
كامل لكن كان ايضا هناك حديث عن مقتل خمسه
جنود اسرائيليين اخرين وذلك بعبوه ناسفه
وكانت مصادر اسرائيليه تحدثت امس لي عن
انه تم استهداف منزل تحصن فيه هؤلاء
الجنود هذه التطورات تاتي بينما استمرت
عمليه القصف المكثفه لعدد من المخيمات نحن
نتحدث تحديدا عن مخيم الصيرات ومخيم
البريج والمغازي ولعلي اشير بالتفصيل الى
منطقه الزوايده هذه المنطقه التي شهدت
عمليه استهداف ملحوظه خلال هذه الايام
حينما نتحدث علي الزويده وتقع الى الجنوب
من النصيرات كان هناك قصف مكثف لمنطقه
الزويده ولكن ايضا كان هناك قصف لمنطقه
تقع الى الشرق من من شارع صلاح الدين وهي
معروفه بمنطقه ل المصدر اذا عمليه قصف في
الزوايده مكثفه ولكن ايضا عمليه قصف مكثفه
في منطقه ل المصدر في هذه في هذه في هذه
المنطقه الوسطى طبعا وسط تساؤلات ايضا عن
عمليات الاستهداف للم المنطقه الوسطى وما
اذا كان هناك سيناريو مع حديث المتحدث
العسكري الاسرائيلي على ان المنطقه الوسطى
هي من المناطق التي يكثف فيها عملياتها
ربما نختم بالحديث عن المنطقه الثالثه وهي
المنطقه الجنوبيه حيث وردت اخبار تابعناها
قبل نحو ساعه عن عمليه استهداف
للمقاومه هنا في المناطق الشرقيه التي
لطالما تحدثنا عنها مناطق الشرقيه
والجنوبيه الشرقيه ظلت محورا للاشتباك بين
المقاومه والقوات الاسرائيليه القسام
تحدثت عن استهداف مركبه من نوع ميركافا
ولكن دبابه من نوع ميركافا وايضا تحدثت عن
استهداف قوه راجله هنا في بني سهيله ولكن
ايضا كان هناك استهداف لا ايضا لقوه رجله
ايضا في منطقه معا في شرق خان يونس اذا
تطورت على اكثر من سعيد على جبهات ثلاث
ولكن الفت هو هذه الانسحابات في الشمال
المعلنه اسرائيليا ولكن ايضا التحركات و
اداء المقاومه في الوسط والجنوب اشرت الى
صعوبات الجيش الاسرائيلي هو البارحه وصفه
بانه اليوم الاقصى اللواء دويري نظرا
للخسائر الكبيره في صفوف جنوده وايضا
ضباطه رغم عدم دقه المعلومات الواضحه حتى
الان ولكن المعروف استهداف عربه نمر وايضا
شاحنه متفجرات والجيش الاسرائيلي طبعا
ينشر صور القتلى من الجنود والضباط بماذا
تخبرك ايه المعركه في ظل سقوط عدد كبير من
القتلى من الجنوب المعارك في القاطع
الاوسط والجنوبي على اشدها وقلنا قديما
بان ما سيجري في منطقه خانيونس
سيكون اكبر واكثر ايلاما مما جرى الشمال
في الشمال وتحدثنا بها اكثر من مره بسبب
طبيعه المنطقه
و طبيعه تمركز القوات النخبه من الفساد
الاخرى الداعمه للقسام يوجد لواء خان يونس
القسام وتوجد كتائب النخبه للجهاد وبقيه
الفسائل الاخرى وبالتالي انشئ غرفه عمليات
مشتركه وبداوا حتى بتنفيذ عمليات مشتركه
يعني حتى وصل التنسيق الى مستوى المهام
الصغيره او الدنيا بدات تنفذ في بعضها ولا
اقول جميعها
بعناصر مشتركه من مختلف الفصائل هذا يعطيك
انطباع عن طريقه اداره المعركه و بان
المعركه في المنطقه الجنوبيه هي اقرب الى
الاداره المركزيه منها في المنطقه
الشماليه التي كانت اداره لامركزيه حيث
كانت كل كتيبه مسؤول كل حي او كل منطقه
لها قوه مخصصه وكل قوه كانت تقاتل
بالتنسيق لكن ليس تحت قياده واح قياده
واحده لكن يبدو لي في الجنوب انه هناك
قياده مشتركه ليس للقسام انما لكافه
الفصائل وهذا س سيوقع الكثير من الالم في
جيش الاحتلال الان اجابه على سؤالك
الاخبار نعم متضاربه متقاطعه كان الحديث
في البدايه عن تسعه ثم جاء الحديث عن
اربعه ثم جاء الحديث عن 30 جريح من بينهم
سته قتلى والعديد الان اختلف اختلف يعني
الان سته من ضمن ال 30 كانوا في شاحنه
ويعتقد انها تعود الى وحده يالوم الهندسيه
التي معنيه مهمتها تدمير الانفاق فبالتالي
هذا يعني ان الشاحنه كانت تحمل متفجرات
وتحمل الجنود ولكن كان هناك الاقدار اخرجت
احد المقاتلين من احد الانفاق فوجد صيدا
ثمينا فاستغل الفرصه وكانت هذه النتيجه
تدمير عربه النمر اعتدنا عليه استخدام تي
بي جي ضد بيت محصن اعتدنا عليه فبالتالي
كان هذا الوضع اللي هو وصفوه بانه اليوم
الاسوا في تاريخ الصراع لكن اشير الى نقطه
واؤكد عليها ان الارقام التي تم الاعلان
عنها لا يمكن ان تمثل الحقيقه لانه حتى
الان هناك اختلاف بين بيانات الجيش
الاسرائيلي و وموقع ولا والذي هو قريب جدا
من الجيش من الجيش الاسرائيلي وكانه يتحدث
باسمه كان هناك تباين في الارقام اضافه
الى صور المروحيات التي تنقل عدد كبير من
من الجرحى اشاره فقط الان هذه الصور هي
صور مجمعه ل نشرها الجيش الاسرائيلي لعدد
من مدرعاته وايضا ما يقول بانها عمليات
لجنوده المشاه في داخل قطاع غزه تحدث عن
الشمال اللواء دويري واشار عبد القادر قبل
قليل الى تقارير تتحدث عن انسحاب او اعاده
انتشار من داخل مناطق قطاع غزه الى غلاف
غزه ما الذي تعرفه حتى الان اطلعت على
العديد من التقارير اشارت بان
مرجعيتها المقاومه ومرجع اخرى مشاهدات
ومرجع اخرى من داخل
الكيان الان كان يوجد ثلاثه فرق تم
سحبها بعد الاعلان عن الدخول في المرحله
الثالثه لكن تم الابقاء على ار
الوي خلال الاسابيع العشره ايام الماضيه
بدات عمليات التخفيف من الغرب والشمال
وبقي الجزء الشرقي لكن اخر المعلومات اللي
استطعنا ان نطل عليها من تقارير مختلفه
المصادر لكنها تحمل درجه كبيره من
المصداقيه انه تم سحب الفرقه
162 الى الجهه الشرقيه من السياج و اعادت
تموضعها على عمق 5 الى 15 ك سحبت الفرقه
252 الى الشمال الى الخلف
من من
السياج الى الخلف من سيد روت وكلا كلا
المجموعتين يعاد تاهيله ولكنه اتخذوا
الوضعيه التهيؤ القتالي اي انهم يعني
جاهزه لاعاده الزج بالمعركه تم الابقاء
على لواء ناحال وعلى لواء مظليين وعلى
وحده يالوم وعلى وحدتين صغير
الحجم من قوات النخبه الخاصه للتعامل مع
ما قيل بانه هناك بقايا مقاتلين يحتمل
وجود رهائن الى وتنفيذ عمليه تدمير
الانفاق بالمقابل الرهائن لم يتم الافراج
على الرهينه لم يستطع تدمير الانفاق اذا
دعني اقول هو بدا بتنفيذ المرحله الثالثه
اذا انتقلنا جنوبا لا قبل الجنوب بالشمال
اكثر من هذا البارحه فصائل فلسطينيه اطلقت
صواريخ من الشمال بجا هذا هذا كان الرد
هذا الرد يعني انا على اساس انه نختصر
الوقت من اجل وقت البرنامج الان بالامس
عندما اطلقت الصواريخ اطلقت في اتجاهين
اطلقت في اتجاه وسط فلسطين وهذا لم يعلن
عن مكان
اطلاقها التي اطلقت الى الغلاف اطلقت من
الشمال وكان الاعلان له اهدافه السياسيه
انه انت تقول سيطرت وانج وانجزت وانهيت
لكنني انا ارسل لك الرساله ان صواريخ
ساطلق من مكان الذي ادعيت انك سيطرت عليه
اذا ذهبنا الى الجنوب مع بدايه المعركه
منطقه
الوسط تم دفع الفرقه 36 المدرعه بثلاثه
الويه وتم تعزيزها بلواء رابع تم اعاده
هيكله هذه القوه وتم اسناد المهمه الى
الفرقه 99 وبالتالي وضع جزء من وحدات
الفرقه 36 مع لواء المظليين مع اضافه لواء
رابع فاصبحت اربعه الويه تم تخصيص لواء
لكل
مخيم لو تعطينا المخيمات لو سمحت لكل مخيم
الان هناك كان لا اقول معارك مستقله لكن
اقول كل وحده مدافعه عن احد المخيمات
تقاتل معركتها بالتنسيق مع الوحدات الاخرى
ماذا فعلت قوات الجيش الاحتلال رغم محاوله
محاصره المخيمات هي فصلتها عن بعضها البعض
وسيطرت على طريق صلاح الدين بدات الان
بتنفيذ مناوره من الشمال الغربي من سيرات
منطقه ابراج الزهراء اندفعت جنوبا مع شارع
الرشيد لو سمحت اندفعت جنوبا مع شارع الر
الرشيد الى جنوب الزوايده وتحاول ان تتجه
شرقا اذا لاحظنا تحت
الزوايده منطقه ليست
كثيفه تحاول ان تعب من هذه المنطقه وتعبر
من جنوب المغازي استمر في السهم الازرق من
جنوب المغازي وصولا الى الشريط الحدود
انها تريد ان تخلق وادي غزه جديد جديد
لماذا اذا منطقه عازله جديده بعد ان عزلت
الشمال تعزل الوسط اذا سيطرت على هذه
المنطقه لا هذه وضعها شوي مختلف اذا سيطرت
على هذه المخيمات ولا اعتقد ذلك تكون
الطريق انفتحت الى دير البلح دير البلح
حتى الان لم تدخل المعركه
كما هي في المناطق الاخرى اذا ذهبنا جنوبا
الى منطقه الجنوب منطقه خان يونس لو سمحت
سريعا منطقه خان يونس تحدثنا كثيرا عنها
تعثرت العمليات هناك عمليه التفاف من
الشمال الجديد في منطقه الجنوب انه طور
هجوما جديدا من منطقه الفخاري
باتجاه بلده دير العدس باتجاه منطقه
المواصي لتلتقي مع التطويق الذي جاء من
الشمال ولكنه حتى هذه اللحظه لم يستطع ان
يحقق ذلك الانجاز واما منطقه شرق خان يونس
فلا يزال القتال في منطقه القراره والزن
وفي منطقه خزاعه بينما عمق بني سهيله لم
يتم الد ط سمح لي هناك تحديث خاصه فيما
يتعلق بالعدد الكبير لقتلى الجيش
الاسرائيلي وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه تقول
بان التحقيق اولي للجيش يؤكد ان تفجير
شاحنه الذخائر بالبريج سببه اطلاق نار من
دبابه اسرائيليه الحديث الان عن مزيد من
ما تسمى بنيران الصديقه النيران الصديقه
لتكن النيران الصديقه لتيك ذلك احنا انا
كانت قراءتي انه ضربه حظ خروج احد المنا
المقاتلين من احد الانفاق في اللحظه
القاتله وجد هدفا دسما ف فعل ما فعل الان
اناب عن انابت عنه د بابه ميركافا هذا
يقودني الى نقطه اخرى ما هي اذا كان هذا
واقع الى ماذا يؤشر يعني كنت من خلال
الحديث قد اغفلت الحديث عنها عندما نتحدث
عن عندما نتحدث عن جنود 30 جندي مع ضباط
يحملوا في شاحنه بها متفجرات هذا يدل على
فشل القاده في قراءه المشهد العسكري الذي
امامه كيف تضع الجنود مع هذا يدل على غباء
يعني ليس لكن الان يعني عاده لا يتم نقل
الجنود مع المتفجرات لا يمكن اه لا يمكن
ام لا يمكن كيف تصف هذا التخبط في اداء
الجيش الاسرائيلي هذا هو يعني و ودبابه
بحسب التحقيق الاولي تقصف شاحنه اس هذا
المستو الحقيقي الان الدبابه يعني لناخذ
بالروايه الاسرائيليه لانها قد تكون محفزه
اكثر دبابه ميركافا تطلق النار على شاحنه
هل يوجد لدى القسام شاحنه عسكريه بتحمل
الجنود يرتدوا اللباس الجيش الاحتلال
ويتحركوا في ارض المعركه القسام وغيرهم
مقاتلين افراد يخرجوا من بين الانقاذ
يخرجوا من الموت ليعي الحياه يخرجوا من
فتحات الانفاق فاذا هذا الذي اطلق القذيفه
هذا مصاب مصاب بالهوس لانه الدبابه تحتاج
الى الى خط نار صحيح يعني لا يمكن ان ان
تكون كالهون مثلا تحتاج الى خط نار مباش
مباشره يعني هذا سلاح رم مباشر ويجب ان
يكون خط النظر مفتوح وبالتالي هذه الدبابه
مزوده باحدث التقنيات
لرمايه من حاله الحركه على هدف متحرك يعني
الدبابات اجيال في بعض الحالات ترمي من
حاله الثبات كانت تكون متحركه تتثبت ترمي
جاء الجيل اللي
بعده بدا يرمي من حاله الحركه الان دخلنا
في مجال ما يطلق عليه فاير اند فورجيت انت
مجرد ان تشاهد الهدف وانت متحرك والهدف
متحرك تصوب ترمي والقذيفة
جيوش العالم الدبابه الاولى
ضابط الثانيه والثالثه ضباط صف ضباط صف
الان لا كلهم ضباط هذا الضابط الذي ا لانه
الرامي لا يرمي الا بامر من الاضط مباشره
ياتيه الامر من الامر والامر يتلقى
المعلومات من ما يطلق عليه قديما المسؤول
عن التقنيات والاجهزه قديما كان يسمى
الاشاره ا اعطاه العمر فرما هذا مسكون
بالرعب كما قتلوا ثلاثه من الرها
رافعي الرايات البيضاء ويتحدثوا بالعبريه
سريعا في حال كان القصد من ما تقول بانه
وسائل الاعلام اسرائيليه تقرير اولي او
تحقيق اولي في حال كان القصد التضليل ماذا
يعني هذا باقت كان بقصد تضليل يعني يعني
يعني كما كما
يقال اذا اراد لا يعني قد يكون ذلك قد
يكون ذلك ولكن حتى التضليل ان ينسب تدمير
هدف به 30 جندي هذه اساءه وطعن في كرامه
واهليه هذا الجيش هو ليبقيها على ان
القسام الذي نفذ اشرف واكرم له شكرا لك
اللواء فيز وير الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي